Så ringer man någon av våra kunder och frågar hur det fungerar, vad har dina kunder för resultat?
Så kommer de alltid säga att det är helt fantastiskt, det har hjälpt, det har förändrat människors liv här på vår klinik, till exempel Life Nordics.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni har omsätt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta men...
Alltså man tar det positivt.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar jag Alexander Bika från Life Nordic till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Tjena, välkommen.
Tusen tack Joel, super spännande att vara med.
Tack för att ni inbjuder dem.
Du har liksom steppat upp för att joinna in.
Du hade typ feber igår men idag ser du piggofräs ut och har bra läkeskött.
Exakt, exakt.
Snabb återhämtningsmåga.
Du, innan vi går in på bolaget, du är någon sorts gammal idrottare, eller gammal idrottare, du är 11 år yngre än mig men du är idrottare i grunden.
Ja, det stämmer.
Stämmer, jag la av faktiskt på elitnivå förra året.
Har det gått ett år?
Jo, det har det gått.
Min sista satsning var för OS 2024, så jag har haft två år i det egentligen.
Och jag har kommit riktigt hela vägen.
Så nu är jag gammal idrottare, kan man kalla det då.
När blir man?
Du är brottare, eller?
Ja, stämmer.
När blir man gammal som brottare?
Jag skulle väl säga att jag slutade lite för tidigt, kanske.
Men det är lite andra saker som prioriteras.
Vi väntar vårt första barn till exempel.
Man är bortade väldigt mycket som är lite rött för det.
Borta över 200 dagar per år på träningslägen eller tävlingar.
Så det är ingenting som jag vill göra när jag har lilla flickan.
Så jag fick ta det beslutet helt enkelt.
Hur känns det att bli farsan?
Skönt spännande.
Så jäkla spännande.
Är du nervös?
Klart, men samtidigt omfattar jag allting.
Det är jobbiga, det är bra, allting, jag tycker att det ska bli skickat.
Har du hört det där uttrycket att Kampsportare alltid får döttrar?
Ja.
Och jag sa hela tiden att det är en pojke, jag vet att det är en pojke, men det blev en flicka.
Jag har bara hört, det finns ett sådant uttryck att Kampsportare alltid får de falte tjejer.
Men det blir spännande, kul.
Brottare, är ni liksom hårdast?
Är det brottare som är den tyngsta sporten overall?
Överlägset, garanterat.
Brottning är fan det jobbigaste.
Jag har provat allt, alla Kampsporter och liksom allting.
Simning är väldigt jävligt jobbigt också.
Ja men brottning är, jag skulle säga, och frågar man de flesta så tycker de att brottning är det jobbigaste de har gjort faktiskt.
Och varför började du?
Jag tänker, är det, man ska gå in, jag tänker någonstans så här som mellanvuxen eller vad man ska kalla det, så kanske man har någon sorts romantiserad bild.
Ja men det är kul att gå in och liksom köra på lite, man får köra mot varandra och ta i och det är lite kamp, man kan romantisera det.
Men jag gissar att första gången du kom i kontakt med brottning, kanske det var typ åtta bast, då måste det varit rätt läskigt att glida in på en klubb där alla ska kasta dig i golvet.
Man tänker ju det, men jag började faktiskt när jag var 14.
Väldigt sent jämfört med andra i landslaget.
Och tog du upp till den nivån, det är fan rätt kaxigt.
De flesta i landslaget under alla de här åren började när de var 5-6 år gamla.
Och så kom jag där när jag var 14, jag har inte varit med i de här.
Men du vet, när man är knatte som det kallas och lär sig alla bitar.
Jag kom in i seniorutruppen direkt, fick stryk varje dag och fick lära mig den hållande vägen.
Varför började du när du var 14?
Vad var det för fel på fotboll?
Ja exakt, jag har provat allt.
Jag har provat allt jag gjorde.
Fotboll, basket, pingis, sinning, flydåt, allting.
Men både pappa, farbror och farfar var brottare.
Och de ville ju pusha mig hela tiden när jag var liten.
Men jag ville ju inte.
Och sen så hittade jag själv, inte enkelt när jag valde hotel.
Jag brukar säga att alla som sysslar med kampsport är folk som kassar på andra sporter.
För det finns liksom inga pengar eller berömmelser i...
Har du tjänat någonting på beratningen?
Jag har en medaljärv där jag tjänade 10 000 kronor och det är i princip allt.
Vad vann du då när du fick den?
10 000 kronor.
Vad var den för?
Det var en Grand Prix i Nynterna Fjäll i Sverige.
Undrar om de som vinner Grand Prix i tennis, undrar vad de får betala.
Ja precis, det är helt rätt.
Brottning är fan inte, det är inga pengar i den sporten.
Man får en påse protein om man ska vara glad.
Och fina öron, och så får man lära sig.
Ja exakt, man ser mörbult där ut.
Vi ska inte fastna i din brottning, men det är ändå lite intressant att du har idrottsbakgrund.
För nu driver ni bolaget Life Nordic.
Vad är Life Nordic för någonting?
Life Nordic är ju, får man säga, slogan.
Det är Skandinavisk främsta leverantör och partner för innovativa teknologier inom hälsa, recovery och longevity.
Och när jag säger främsta så är det väl inte nödvändigtvis storleken, men vi har verkligen det bredaste sortimentet i brantmen.
Det är snart 20 stycken olika teknologier i olika kategorier.
Så vi är väldigt breda i sortimentet.
Och det är därför vi har kunder som är allt från gym, kliniker, spa, hotell, nya satsningar inom longevity.
Ni har varit igång i tre-fyra år eller nånting, fyra år kanske.
Var longevity trendigt redan då?
För nu börjar longevity komma, det börjar bli lite mer mainstream.
För några år sen var det mer lite halv-weirda människor som var in i det.
Hur såg det ut där i starten och varför gick ni in i det där?
Jag tror, jag personligen är ju med i idrotten, så hela mitt liv har det handlat om det här med prestation, återhämtning, för att kunna vara på topp.
Så jag har alltid haft det där tänket.
När vi har varit på olimpiska center internationellt, då har jag märkt att de har de här grejerna.
De har de här iskalla kammarna som man går in i.
De jobbade med Syre.
Det har funnits internationellt.
Tittar man mot USA så har det funnits länge.
Idrottslag, jag har ju alltid exponerats för det, men sen har jag inte riktigt, varför har vi inte det i Sverige?
Och sen kanske de toppfotbollsspelarna kanske har det, men återigen bråttade, vi har ju aldrig fått ta del av det.
Och sen så, jag och Elias, vi är badumsvänner, vi gick på samma dag.
Vi stod ihop av våra hjärnor och tillsammans, det här borde vi göra i Sverige.
Det här borde vi göra i Skandinavien, det finns inte riktigt.
Och det var faktiskt sju år sedan.
Så det var ett tag sedan ändå, och vi var ju väldigt, väldigt tidiga med de här hjärnorna.
För ni säljer ju, som du säger, ni säljer ju ganska avancerad teknologi ändå, eller ganska stora produkter och sådär.
Och vi jobbar ju inte riktigt i samma bransch, men jag vet ju ändå hur de här mässorna ser ut och hur man går och pratar om man ska få exklusivitet på vissa avtal och sånt där.
Ni kommer där, och speciellt om det var sju år sedan, så ni är ju inga gamla killar då och vår bransch är lite...
Man ska gärna vara 45-50 för att sitta där och sajna avtal.
Den är rätt trög liksom, vår bransch.
Hur fick ni de här avtalen på de här riktiga maskinerna?
De måste bara tänkt hur fan ska ni betala detta typ?
Eller hur gick de dialogerna?
Det är en väldigt bra fråga faktiskt.
Det har varit en utmaning.
Hur gammal var vi när vi var 21-22?
Så i många ögon var vi bara va?
Ska de göra någonting och hur kan de?
Men ja, vi har alltid haft, alltså båda två, vi har alltid haft det här drivet.
Vi har alltid haft de här ambitionerna.
Så jag tror att det kanske visade sig.
Jag vet att vi åkte till Italien, till en av våra första leverantörer.
Så istället för att skriva massa skontor så vet du vad, vi åker dit, vi kvarmar dem.
Vi tror på det vi kan göra.
Så vi satt och slängde med ägaren för företaget, ett av deras största spaföretag.
De käkade middag och bara var oss själva och sa att lita på oss.
Vi kommer att göra det här och vi kommer att kunna göra det här.
Vi är inte det största bolaget, vi är inte de äldsta entreprenörerna med den längsta erfarenheten, men vi kommer att göra det.
De trodde på oss så det började väl där.
Sedan gjorde man resultat med Devilinventören och det företaget och så kunde man visa det till nästa och sen till nästa och nästa.
Sedan skapade man ett valumärke och så och flyttade på.
Vad är Elias, det är din affärspartner, det var ni som startade bolaget ihop.
Vad är hans bakgrund?
Du sa att ni gick på dagis ihop men är båda idrotterna?
Nej, Elias gick den akademiska vägen, så han har studerat och i början så var det så.
Jag brottades upp hela tiden och var borta hela tiden.
Elias pluggade i Lund, på Lunds universitet, ekonomi och så.
Han har en bakgrund i det akademiska och jag har det i idrottsvärlden.
Tillsammans tror jag att vi har fått ihop något väldigt bra som kompletterat.
Så det är Elias bakgrund.
Och jag tänker att det är en sak att ha någon sorts, du vet, man har någon sorts ungdomligt driv och såhär naivitet nästan.
Man åker ner och bara fan det är klart ni ska säga till oss för vi vill så gärna.
Sen är det en helt annan sak och för vad kostar, vad ligger liksom er att snittköp på?
Vad ligger en sån här stor infrarörd maskin?
Det är liksom inte en sån där liten ögonmask, utan det är en stor, ett stort as liksom.
Ja det är det, det är det, det går väl från allt från 100 000 till 1,5 miljoner för de olika maskinerna, så det är väldigt brett gatan.
Jag skulle säga standard kanske är runt 300 000, 300-400 000 för en maskin.
Sen är det ju leasing då.
Kan du ta oss med till det första riktiga säljet när ni fick igenom och hur det gick till?
Jo jag ska förklara.
Den första kunden, det var här i Malmö.
Vi hade ingen likviditet.
Det var 25 000 i aktiekapitalet.
Allting var organiskt.
Vi kunde klart printa ut flyers och brokirer och gå och dela ut i köpcentrum.
Så när vi började dra hela den här historien, jag minns att den första kunden, vi tänkte ju hur ska vi någonsin kunna köpa in den här maktfattet.
Det är ju högst inköpsvärde också.
Så hur ska vi kunna köpa in det, innan vi kan sälja vidare.
Men den första kunden någonsin faktiskt köpte hela maskinen och fattura i förskott 50 procent.
Så vi fick in 50 procent av det stora beloppet som finansierade hela inköpet och frakten och allting så att sedan generera och få restriana 50 procent.
Så lite tur för jag vill säga.
Fan man måste ha lite tur.
Då hade vi ju inga leasing partners heller eller någonting som kunde hjälpa oss.
Hur gjorde ni innan ni åkte på det här säljmötet?
Hur besökte ni kunder på den tiden?
Hur såg försäljningstratten ut back in the days?
Du sa att ni gick runt med flyers på, vad tänker jag, bara till random folk eller?
Det fanns ingen struktur liksom.
Man har ju blivit bättre på det såklart, men fortfarande så finns det ju, man ställer ju fortfarande frågan till sig själv liksom, är det så här riktiga företag jag gör?
Är det här strukturen jag ska ha eller finns det något bättre eller liksom, gissar jag bara nu liksom, såklart.
Nej, det var faktiskt Word of Mouse.
Det var en klinik som ville satsa med på hälsa, det var lite mer åt skönhetshållet.
Jag hade sett det här och, i och med att det var en man, så åkte vi ju dit och satt oss ner och pratade med henne som ägde stället och förklarade allting och hon var väldigt positiv till det och trodde väldigt mycket på det så, ja, det funkade väl.
Hur lång tid tog det innan ni kunde leva på bolaget?
Du sa att ni har varit igång i sju år men, jag gissar att ni inte har fått lönen från detta på sju år.
Nej, helt rätt.
Det tog väl tre år innan vi tog ut någonting av det huvudtaget.
Och det var ju, som sagt, för att Elias pluggade heltid och jag faktiskt jobbade också.
Först 50 procent, sen 45 och sen heltid som verksamhetschef.
Och satsade på blåtningen samtidigt som vi drev företaget.
Vi kunde inte ut någonting, nej.
Men vi hade möjligheten att kunna göra det ändå, säger han om, för att vi gjorde annat samtidigt.
Nej, annars vet jag inte hur det hade gått.
Det är liksom att tala om barn och så.
Är man i en annan situation, när man är äldre och har barn och plikter, så kan jag tänka mig att det är väldigt svårt att gerära något sådant här om man inte har medel från början, när man kan starta.
Och sen någonstans där, jag gissar bara, grejen är att du och jag har sett sig en gång tidigare, vi har sett ut kötat lite, så det är därför jag lite, lite känner till Storin, även om det var ett tag sedan.
Så att folk förstår varför jag pratar som att jag har någon sorts koll.
Men lite, lite likt, och så är det ändå i lite liknande bransch.
Men jag tänker här, när började ni känna att fan, det funkar liksom?
Alltså när kom, du säger att är det så här riktiga bolag?
Absolut, man kanske aldrig riktigt känner sig som ett riktigt bolag, men när blev känslan att fan, det här kommer att bli bra.
När vågar du säga upp dig från jobbet, eller har du sagt upp dig från jobbet?
Jajaja, det har jag inte.
När vågade ni ta domstegen, vad var det som var igång då?
Tre-fyra år sedan, som vi verkligen kände att okej, det här är någonting, för man märkte ju redan för tre år sedan, att det här är inte bara en trend längre ut, men det här kommer att integreras i alla, på hotell, på gym, så vi märkte ju det här, och inte bara när vi pratade med folk, men vi fick mycket mer intresse, mycket mer affärsförfrågan, såklart försäljningen tog fart, och det är ju det tydligaste krittor på att det här funkar och vi gör någonting rätt.
Så jag skulle säga, för två tre år sedan, när det tog fart så kände vi att okej, det här måste vi lägga all vår energi på, som vi gör nu.
Och vad är anledningen till att, för nu är ni väl enbart riktade mot företag, eller liksom stora produkter, eller vad jag ska kalla det.
Det kanske finns någon random norsk miljonär där som köper någon skum.
Det finns de här stycken, och det är helt galet men.
Visst är ni ut och monterar utrustningen också?
Ja, oftast.
Oftast är det jag, Elias och någon till om det behövs som är ute och personligen installerar och träffar kunden.
Ja, fortfarande.
Och jag hoppas att vi kan hålla det.
Har ni också fått de här sjuka, för jag och en kollega är ju ofta ut och monterar våra grejer.
Och ibland får man liksom, det är en privatperson som köper gym för en kvarts miljon och så åker man ut och bara, ja du bor såhär, okej, ja men jag fattar att det här är inga pengar för dig.
Har du sett några sådana riktigt bizarra?
Ja, absolut.
För mig är den världen, som jag har växt upp ganska med en ensamstående mamma.
Det var inget wow överhuvudtaget.
Det var tufft emellanåt.
Och sen att se det nu, det var för mig helt galet.
Det var liksom att komma hem och sen en person då som hade tre lyxbilar i sitt karak, en dinkällare, en hemmabio.
Absurt, helt galet.
Och då förstår man ju att det här får honom med bara små lägsaker.
Jag vill förbättra min hälsa lite grann.
Så jag köper in där liksom.
Men ja, så det har funnits några sådana under åren har vi inte sett fatt på.
Fan jag kommer ihåg, vi var ut hos en kund och han gjorde detta i någon sorts uthus, byggde han sitt gym och så när vi går på toaletten där så ser vi att toalettborsten har ett märke på sig, alltså ett lyxmärke.
Och vi bara, fan det här är en sjukt, vi måste googla detta och se om detta är en grej liksom.
Så gick vi in och kollade, då såg vi att den toalettborsten kostade 10 000.
Nej, det är helt alldeles, jag förstår inte.
Vad fan, och så, fan vi förhandlade om monteringskostvärden här, det borde vi inte ha gjort liksom.
Nej, exakt.
Jag vet inte, det känns som att jag, hur mycket pengar jag någonsin skulle ha, det hade jag aldrig tidigare gjort någonsin.
Nej, det är ju riktigt knäppt faktiskt.
Samtidigt, vi gör ju sälj dit, så det är bara att vara tacksam och glad liksom.
Men det jag tänkte säga med detta var att nu är det att fokus stå på företag.
Jag hade Lucas här från Flowlife, om du känner till det bolaget i båden, de säljer ju mer, vad ska man säga, de säljer erkategori fast mot privatpersoner mer.
Hur kommer det sig att ni inte rör er mot privatperson som är mycket, på ett sätt kanske enklare i marknad och som går att driva mer med klassisk e-handel och få volym i.
Ni blir på något sätt så utbildningstunga, ni måste ut och snacka med kunderna, förklara vad de ska tjäna på det.
Jag tänkte att jag själv hade tänkt, fan det här är en enkel väg.
Ja, jag lyssnar faktiskt på avsnittet.
Jag tycker det är riktigt grymt jobbat av dem, av Lucas och teamet på Flawless.
Jag minns att jag var faktiskt en av deras första, ska man kalla det, influencers.
Ja, med pistolen och den här massa akut, minns jag.
Så det är riktigt coolt att se hur de har utvecklats faktiskt.
Men precis, vi säljer nästan exklusivt till företag, som sagt vissa privatpersoner och så.
Vi har tänkt på det såklart.
Jag tror det är väl två saker som har gjort att vi inte har tagit steget.
Det har vi utformat en expertis inom B2B.
Och vi vill fortsätta att utvecklas och bli bäst inom just den nischen.
Och sen, jag vet inte, kanske det låter lite dumt, men jag ser inte riktigt meningen med det heller.
B2C eller D2C innebär såklart större volymer, absolut fler kunder men det gäller också fler reklamationer, större lager med personal, fler leveranser, för kanske samma marginal som en high-ticket-produkt hade genererat.
Så, jag vet inte, absolut processen som du säger, utbildningen och allting, är ju längre och mer omfattade inom B2B.
Men jag vet inte, vi ska jobba med kundrelationer, större projekt, satsningar och så här.
Jag tror i alla fall några år framåt kommer vi nog att hålla oss inom B2B.
Men vi har tänkt på det såklart.
Hur ser det ut nu, är ni i Sverige eller är ni i andra länder också?
Främst Sverige fortfarande.
Vi har mycket mer att göra i Sverige.
Men vi säljer till Danmark, till Norge, vi har sålt till hela världen egentligen.
Vi har ju sånt till USA, vi säljer mycket till Italien och Spanien också.
Man får väl säga hela världen, men Sverige är fortfarande till 70% kanske.
Men tanken är ju, det är en av utvecklingarna som vi håller på med, hur slö det är ju, expansionen internationellt med suddistribution och lite olika strategier.
Fan jag undrar om inte det var det vi sågs för första gången eller något sånt där.
Det kanske inte var men jag bara skulle kunna inbilla mig att det säkert var att jag tänkte ja skulle inte jag kunna få investera i er eller något sånt där.
Jag kan bara tänka mig att jag har tänkt den tanken i alla fall.
För jag tyckte att den marknaden började röra på sig någonstans när vi snackade i alla fall.
Och jag tänker fortfarande någonstans att även om longevity och rehab och allt detta har börjat bli mycket mer av en en bass och folk pratar om det.
Folk är väldigt fascinerade av handen här.
Visst heter han Brian Johnson?
Hanssons?
Brian Johnson, ja precis.
Exakt.
Och det har liksom blivit mycket mer mainstream, men det är fortfarande extremt icke etablerat.
Det finns liksom inga riktiga varumärken än, det finns inga riktiga.
Det är fortfarande ingen stor marknad på det sättet.
Det är mest lite kosttillskott om man ska vara helt krass.
Det är de som har börjat tjäna pengar kanske.
Så har ni börjat fundera på liksom, att vi ska ta in en massa kapital och etablera det hos oss som man handlar.
Återigen det är klart att vi har kommit på tal, det är såklart för man tänker ska vi växa snabbare.
Och vi har fått flera förslag.
Ja, jag tror att det var det vi träffades för, för att diskutera lite möjligheter faktiskt.
Så du har nog helt rätt men, speciellt efter bokslutet förra året så har vi fått flera förslag.
Men sen dag ett har vi sagt att vi aldrig ska ge bort några andel eller snor.
Det har klubbat det.
Vi har en väldigt stark tro på att vi kan bygga det organiskt, till den storleken som vi vill.
Och vi vill fortsätta att ha den här kontrollen som man har, när man är två vänner som äger 50-50.
Och vi behöver inte rätta oss efter blodtörstiga investerare varje år, som sätter press på en.
Och det är väl en av anledningen till att vi driver eget och har haft eget företag innan.
Och att vi båda har förväntat oss att vi inte kan vara anställda.
För att vi klarar inte av det där, att man har någon som säger till en vad man ska göra, när man ska göra det.
Och ja, jag vet att många i vår generation speciellt, ju värre letar efter den här snabba framgången.
Och jag vet att om vi hade tagit in kapital, så hade vi säkert kunnat växa snabbare.
Det är väl, till vilket pris, om man vill tänka då.
Easy come, easy go brukar man säga.
Jag tänker att jag kan argumentera för att ni ska ta in och det, men det gör ju folk mot mig också.
Jag har inte heller tagit in något kapital och folk har ju alla år sagt, fan är du dum i huvudet typ, ta in pengar du, ni är så jävla lagerintensiva.
Men det är ju ni också.
Ni köper ju dessutom bedrövligt stora sällanköpsvaror som liksom inte driver volym.
Hur har ni löst hela problematiken kring alltså inköp kontra sälj mot kunder, kontra, du pratade lite grann om leasing och sånt där, men det finns ju fortfarande en likviditetsproblematik i er genre.
Hur har ni jobbat kring det där?
Ja, eftersom att snittrådet där är väldigt högt så är kunderna oftast okej med en längre leveranstid.
Vilket gör att vi kan göra inköp från vår partner, tillverkare, och då kanske kunder har betalat en deposition, vissa betalar det på faktur, och då har man 50% och sen 50% efter.
Och sen när det kommer till leasing, så får vi hjälp ibland från leasingbolagen nu när det är större volymer.
Då kan de hjälpa till med någon form av förskottbetalning.
Men vi har ju byggt det organiskt, och likviditeten är så pass bra i bolaget att vi har aldrig, ja några gånger när det har varit större kunder, som verkligen lägger en väldigt stor order direkt.
Har vi behövt ha, får man checkkredit eller så får man hjälp oss.
Men annars har vi alltid haft möjligheten, tack vare likviditeten att kunna täcka det.
Ja, det är bra jobbat.
Fan det är knepigt.
Hur har ni fått kunden att gå med på det här 50-50-uppläggetet?
Det har jag fan aldrig, jag har fått igenom.
Ja, jag vet inte.
Är det charmen?
Bra fråga.
Ja, det är charmen.
Exakt, det är charmen.
Nej, alltså det är väl den policyn vi har haft och det har funkat.
Ibland har man väl såklart att det har varit 30 procent ibland och så här.
Ja.
Men det har inte varit något speciellt egentligen.
Ja, jag bara älskar det.
Ibland kommer det så fruktansvärt självklara lösningar.
Alltså likviditet är ju bedrövligt för alla med stora köp och vi, ibland kan vi sälja ett gym för en och en halv miljon, då har vi först varorna på lager, sen håller vi dem där, vi kanske ska vänta tre månader tills vi ska montera.
Sen monterar man, sen skickar man ut faktura med 30 dagar, fan då har vi legat ut det med det i liksom fyra månader.
Varför har jag inte bara sagt att när ni signar så ska ni betala 30 procent på denna?
För kunden hade säkert godkänt det.
Det är bara att man aldrig har tänkt på på lösningen.
Man är ju lite dum i huvudet liksom.
Du har precis sparat in mig alla likviditetsproblem i gymkompaniiet härifrån.
Jag skickar folk tur av på det.
Han Brian Johnson som vi snackade om, det är väl det mest välkända namnet i den här rörelsen.
Visst, jag såg du dök upp på en bild någonstans, jag vill minnas att jag såg dig med honom någonstans, eller det var något event.
Berätta om hur man når ut där, vad är eventen och hur är han som människa?
Är han lite skum eller?
Lite grann får man säga.
Hoppas att han hör det.
Det var på ett event i Stockholm, så det var ett superkunder där vi var partner.
Vi hade en sån där interaktiv, interactive area där man fick prova på några av våra teknologier.
Han var moderator då, Brian Johnson, och ett flertal andra väldigt kända namn i branschen var där.
Det var jättespännande att få lyssna på alla och träffa dem.
Brian Johnson, vi träffade honom på en VIP-mida senare under kvällen, efter evältet, där de samlade, stå och hade middag och pratade och allting, men vi hade inte pratat så mycket med honom, han var ju väldigt upptagen och så här.
Men han var väldigt snäll och han tittade på produkten som vi hade där och var väldigt cool för att det är ett torrt isbad som vi hade på plats som folk fick prova.
Så han tittade och var wow, det hade jag aldrig sett innan.
Försök att man säger, ja det här borde jag ha en.
Eller, den här borde du visa upp i dina videos.
Nej men det var coolt.
Kan du känna att det blir lite nerdigt ibland?
Blir du trött på att snacka hälsa och longevity och skadeåterhämtning och lyssna på folks fucking stories om deras?
Så här är jag, ja ja jag vet.
Ja lite grann, lite grann.
Jag tror att det blir väldigt överdrivet många gånger när man pratar om just det här med longevity som det kallas.
Alltså det blir för mycket och för överdrivet liksom.
Jag tror fortfarande på de fundamentala grejerna måste finnas där.
Sön, post, motion, det sociala.
Alltså utan det där så spelar ingenting roll.
Alla våra maskiner är fantastiska och kan ge de här extra procenten i prestation, sön, inflammation.
Men har du inte grundpedlarna, då spelar det ingen roll då.
Då kan man lika gärna skita i att göra den här rörelse-
eller syretherapi och så här.
Så jag tror att många tar ett kosttillskott och säger att det här kommer att förändras.
Så sover de ändå fyra timmar och rörelseklart.
Jag tycker att man måste ha koll på det där först innan man hälsar in på det allt annat.
Jag köper det, jag håller med.
Finns det någon, om du går igenom era olika teknologier, finns det någon som är flippig eller som är udda?
Hur bestämmer ni vad som ska få finnas i sockumentet?
För någonstans, det som du har nämnt hittills är ju jävligt etablerat, och kallbad, om man skulle ta en sån grej, har ju liksom varit etablerat inom idrott, hur länge som helst.
Det är bara nu folk åker på nåt retreat och betalar typ 5000 spänn för att bada kallt.
Går ni på skumma grejer eller etablerade grejer?
Hur gör ni urvalet?
Det är väldigt viktigt för oss, i och med också min bakgrund i idrotten och doping, och jag har ju format mig en...
För mig är det väldigt viktigt att det finns evidens i det vi gör, det vi jobbar med och det vi säljer såklart.
Placebo är också superviktigt, absolut.
Men när vi tittar på de här teknologierna som vi tar in, och vi har faktiskt tagit in maskiner tidigare och provat, och insett att det här passade inte oss.
Det var inte så som vi tänkte.
Då har vi tagit på det från sortimentet, så att vi är väldigt öppna också för att vi kan ha fel.
Men vi gör betydligt mer research varje gång innan vi tar in någonting nu.
Vi jobbar alltid med världsledande leverantörer, partners, fabriker, som gör att vi kan känna oss bekväma i att det här är någonting som faktiskt är bra, och det finns evidens, vi tittar alltid på studier, vetenskapliga artiklar kring allting.
Och jag tror att det är mycket av det förtroendet som vårt varumärkligt utstrålar också.
Det kommer liksom i två delar, det här med förtroendet.
Och det visar sig att det faktiskt gör skillnad i människors liv.
Alltså ringer man någon av våra kunder och frågar hur det funkar, vad har dina kunder för resultat?
Så kommer de alltid säga att det är helt fantastiskt.
Det har hjälpt, det har förändrat människors liv här på vår klinik tack vare Life Nordic.
Det är väldigt skickigt att veta det också.
Rätta mig gärna om jag har fel, men jag gissar att någonstans när man kanske började sälja in de här produkterna så hade man ett sätt att prata mot kund.
Men med tiden så gissar jag att det blir väldigt fokuserat på hur kunden ska tjäna pengar.
För i slutändan måste de kunna betala sin investering.
Är det så säljcykeln ser ut eller hur sker redan tratt ut, eller vad jag ska kalla det?
Ja, det är väl två delar.
Fördelar och effekten av behandlingen.
Och sen det ekonomiska.
Kan du tjäna pengar på det här?
Alla det är väl företag, alla måste ha en makovolet så att det måste finnas en ekonomisk binging i det också för en klinikägare givetvis.
Men alltså fan nu, om man säger så ser det ut, det har ju blivit mycket mer, i början var det ju supertufft, då var det ju mycket mer push, alltså vi var för no, alltså cold calls, cold emails och så.
Nu har det blivit mycket mer en pull fall, eller om man säger så.
Det är liksom ads som skickas till hemsidan, och för att formulär.
Nu har vi integrerat en automatisering, som automatiserar nötesbokningar, konsultationer, dämbesök ofta och sen återkoppling och sen försäljning.
Så det är så det ser ut.
Men ja absolut, kliniker måste köra pengar också, så är det.
Och när blir Sverige en marknad där man kan driva rena rehabcenter?
För nu känns det som att det kanske är ett hotell som köper in en grej, eller ett spa som köper in en sidogrej.
Finns det rena rehabcenter i Sverige när de pengar finns marknaden?
Ja, det finns.
Det är väldigt tidigt fortfarande som du säger att det endast är ett tidskott och ett komplement.
Att det bara handlar om det.
Vi har ju en kund i Göteborg som är i vren ord att recoverycenter.
De heter Recovery Lab och det är det de pushar på.
De har ingen träning eller så utan de har återhämtning och biohacking så att säga.
Och de kör på, det är ju mycket i början såklart som för alla.
Men de har växt det senaste året då.
Så att vi får bara, och sen så är det många sådana här liknande projekt som startar.
Främst i Stockholm då.
Det är svårt kanske att göra det i Eslöven eller en liten ort.
Men i Stockholm så ser vi ganska tydligt att det är många sådana här recoverycenter som startar upp.
Men det är fortfarande i början, det är det.
Vad är det du ser, om vi bara snackar lite longevity och liknande eller återhämnd.
Vad kallar ni det själva?
Har ni något namn för hela det här som vi säljer?
Ja, longevity, hälsooptimering, gillar jag.
Ja, wellness bland annat.
Det finns många, Mastavo.
Vad är det som är etablerat nu och vad tror du kommer bli nästa etablerade, inte trend då utan som verkligen blir så här, det här kommer börja dyka upp på gymmen?
Mm, bra fråga.
Jag tror att en liten, simpel grej som jag personligen gillar, du var inne lite på det tidigare, det är kontrasten mellan kallt och vatt.
Det är kyla värme.
Jag tror att det är en sån simple grej och jag tror att verkligen alla mår bra av det och det är superbra för kroppen.
Jag tror att till exempel gym, jag tror att det kommer att vara en av de populära grejerna som gym integrerar.
Det är kontrast terapi, det kallas för.
Så ett rum där man har en bastu och två kallbarn kanske.
Det tror jag då flesta kommer integrera.
Sedan finns det ju en massa annat som klart.
Syreterapi är också superintressant och sen så jobbar vi även med kroppsskallning.
Så vi har det också, speciellt för gym, är det också väldigt intressant att ta in.
För man kan då mäta resultaten på ett helt annat sätt.
Så när det är lämna att få ett krypto på att deras pt-program funkar liksom.
Så det tror jag också kommer vara populärt.
Finns det någon sån här trend som bara den sker sig?
Ni försökte testa den och sen bara nej, det här var inget som tyckte om.
Vi har faktiskt kvar det mesta i sortimentet.
Det är väl en av två maskiner som vi tar kvar.
Det var egentligen inte mer praktiska anledningar till det.
Vi hade en liten maskin som man behandlade lokala skador med minus 70 grader.
Det var ju superbra.
Men gasen som man behöver koldioxid för, det blev väldigt dyrt precis efter allt som hände i världen för några år sedan.
Så att vi kunde ta kvaren.
Hur ser framtiden ut för Life Nordic?
Vad omsätter ni nu?
Vad tror du på 2026?
Vad är den stora svårigheten här i nästa steg?
Nästa steg för oss, tror jag att vi kommer inte ta in fler teknologier, i alla fall i ett år.
Så vi känner att det vi har nu kommer vi att satsa på och ha kvar.
Men vi kommer inte ta in fler, vi kommer inte utöka utbyret.
Viktigt för oss är att börja med subdistribution, som innebär egentligen att vi hittar partners internationellt som vill representera Mephonovo i deras marknad helt enkelt och ta in de maskinerna som vi har.
För vi har ju två delar av företaget, det ena är redistribution av väl etablerade varumärken som redan finns därute i världen och den andra sidan är maskiner som vi har tagit fram och som vi har utvecklat tillsammans med fabriker runt om i världen.
Så att det är väldigt viktigt för oss de kommande åren att det utvecklas på det sättet att hitta partners runt om i världen.
Jag tror att det är det bästa sättet för oss att växa internationellt.
Fan jag visste inte att ni hade utvecklat egna, vad är era egna?
Det borde jag ju fråga dem först.
Vad har ni tagit fram själva?
Det är lite olika med radioterapiprodukterna.
Det är utvecklat av oss.
Även de här stora poddarna som man ligger i och sådana grejer.
Precis, det är vårt varumärke.
Kallbaden är ju helt vårt varumärke också.
Det har vi också utvecklat tillsammans med det här italienska företaget som vi var hos och som var i våra första leverantörer.
Så det, och sen så några stycken till i sortimentet som vi själva uppvärderade.
Okej, hur var det att ta fram eget varumärke så jävla tidigt på resan?
Jag vet att ni har varit i sju år och det finns massa människor som, men på något sätt så tror jag att om man lyssnar och man själv driver i en handel så får man förstå att cyklerna är så mycket långsammare när det gäller så bara stora produkter så att det är liksom på något sätt tidigt i resan.
För att det kräver liksom sådana volymer och så mycket pengar på något sätt.
Hur fan kunde ni få igenom så många stora produkter så tidigt?
Hur gjorde ni?
Ja det är en bra fråga också.
Jag tror att det handlar om, vi var ju där vi reste, mycket till olika fabriker i Europa, i Asien och träffade företag och förstod processen, förstod kostnaderna och förstod hur kan vi göra det här, är det realistiskt för oss just nu?
Och sen så började vi egentligen med honom minns rätt nu men jag tror det var radius för den, ja faktiskt.
Och så började vi med det, och på den tid var det ingen exklusivitet eller något sånt heller, för då hade det ju kostat mycket mer för oss och vi hade ju inte möjligheten till det, så då var vi ju inte det.
Och återigen, en produkt, två produkter, kund för kund, organiskt, och bara tog det sakta men säkert.
Var ni inte rädda att grejerna skulle liksom inte vara bra?
På något sätt är detta en, ja, alltså det tog ju, förrförra året tror jag att vi tog fram våra första elektriska produkter.
För elektriska produkter är ju svinjobbigt för det är där det blir fel.
Det är en helt annan grej att ta fram en hjärnskiva än att ta fram ett löpande.
Och det här är ju någonting som folk verkligen kommer att använda.
Hur jobbar man där för att säkerställa att det blir bra?
Ja, för det första är det att man åker och provar det.
Och får känna på det och få en känsla för det.
Och då märker man snabbt att det är skillnad på kvalitet och kvalitet.
Så det var väldigt viktigt också.
Vad var det sämsta du såg?
Jag ska inte gå in på detaljer men det var väldigt plastigt kan man säga.
Man måste göra sin research i själva företagen.
Vad är det för företag?
Hur mycket säljer de globalt till vilka varumärken?
När man ändå är någonstans och ser och pratar och förstår att den här produkten har faktiskt sålts i 20-25 år.
Då får man ju ett bra förtroende för det.
Och sen får man prova.
Vi beställer ju hit samples, som det kallas för.
Och provar det själva på kontoret.
Men tog ni hem första sändningen av sådana här pods till exempel?
Kroner ni det på en container eller skickar ni hem några pallar?
En.
En styck?
En styck.
Fan vad roligt, hur var det att lägga den nåden gick de med på det fabriket?
Ja det gjorde de.
Så det är charmen igen antar jag.
Fan, ni kommer undan med mycket där.
Känner du, vet du vilka bastsaunakillarna det är?
Ja, just det.
Jag hade sett att, jag minns inte namnet, men jag har pratat med dem, jag har haft kontakt med dem.
För de gjorde ju också, de satt bara upp ett tält nere vid vattnet och så kom det 100 kunder och bara signade upp på att de ville köpa sånt där.
Och jag bara tänkte, det är sånt aldrig hänt mig.
Jag har inte den charmen som funkar på folk, men uppenbarligen är det en ögonöppnare för människor.
Har det hänt som sista grej, har ni fått hem någonting som varit riktig skit någon gång?
Ja, det har vi.
Vad var det sämsta ni har fått hem?
Måste vara en form av radiusmaskin.
Det var inte podden, det var en sån här panel.
Som inte är för hela kroppen, men det är en panel.
Och där visste vi, och där såg vi faktiskt inte det innan, utan där tog vi risken till att bara ställa händer.
Och sen fick vi mötas av att det här kommer aldrig funka, det här kan vi inte stå bakom, det går liksom inte.
Det var lite lampor med röd papp framför oss.
Ja, men typ.
Och sen visste jag också att det var ett kallbad också i början, som vi tänkte att det här var inte heller bra.
Verkligen inte sån här.
Jag tror verkligen man underskattar hur mycket man måste åka ner på plats och se vad som faktiskt sker.
Ett stort stort tack för att vi fick komma med i podden.
Tusen tack!
Det här är sjukt, vi måste googla detta och se om detta är en grej.
Då såg vi att den toalettborsten kostade 10 000.
Det var alltså...
Vad fan!
Och så...
Fan, vi förhandlade om...